so dunker first of all at the uk's big
oil companies say they've got a plan
they say they're going to get to net
zero by 2050. so should they be
persuaded to
cut their fossil fuel production more
quickly and if so how do you go about it
well the first thing is the
international energy agency report this
year stated that we we could not afford
to invest any new investments in new
fossil fuels if we are to reach net zero
2050. so the very first step we need to
take is to end investments in new fossil
fuels
and that can be done in two ways the
government needs to regulate it and
secondly the banks need to stop lending
billions of dollars to the all
corporations to expand their current
exploration and and projects
then we need them we need to look at how
we phase out over the next 10 to 15
years the remaining production
okay and let's take a look at why we're
talking about this vicky because here
this is what the carbon tracker has said
about fossil fuel investment they say 13
billion pounds of fossil fuel investment
approved in 2020 was inconsistent with
global warming of 1.65 degrees not to
mention the 1.5 degree target so do you
think the government should step in to
stop investment in fossil fuel companies
right now
i think there is no doubt that something
needs to happen if we are to meet the
targets but it's worth bearing in mind
that
in fact if you look at the energy
companies the independent energy
companies which are funded by central
banks uh sorry by the banking system
which the central banks of course
control and therefore can do something
about it
they only i think um account for
something like uh 15
of um production some 12 percent of oil
and gas reserves so quite a lot of the
rest is held by national
uh oil companies uh
run by states so countries basically own
them
and they are subject actually to very
different rules so we got to watch what
we do in terms of how we uh address it
by just attacking if you like
western energy companies that for the
moment anyway provide quite a lot of
what we need certainly in the west
although we sing periods of course with
oil crisis when we have been relying
quite a lot on uh other parts of the
world to provide us with oil which have
of course led to very substantial
increases in prices and drops in in gdp
and so on in the western world
recessions and and so on so we have to
be a little bit careful uh about wishing
to if you like uh attack firms which at
present provided with quite a lot of our
needs and second what they do
yeah it's not a question of attacking
these companies these corporations what
carbon tracker is saying clearly
investing billions and trillions of
dollars in new fossil fuel investments
is actually endangering those companies
future
many some some old companies have
already moved out of oil and gas to
renewables such as orested and what
they're saying is that if if if bp and
shell invest trillions of dollars
including the state corporations around
the world they're investing in in in
products that cannot be sold and that's
a disaster for the future economy and
you're right with the international
energy agency report didn't refer just
to western oil corporations but to all
oil corporations whether state or
private so it's clear absolutely clear
from an economic point of view investing
in new fossil fuels is actually putting
a a suicide note to the future of our
economy and we cannot afford it and i
would say to people today they really
need to look at where their bank
accounts are and to ensure that they
switch them away from banks are
investing in in destruction of our
future
you